Israel's elections and with no clear
winner president Trump receives support
from a feisty corey lewandowski
and the wolf scolds come for Joe Biden
and comedy i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show absolute chaos and this
Israeli election I will bring you the
results and I will explain how those
results work I am familiar with the
system over there we'll get to that in
just one second first Saudi oil fields
are under attack increasing geopolitical
insecurity skyrocketing national debt it
is the perfect storm for the rally in
gold right this instant is there any
gold protecting your portfolio and
retirement savings can you afford
another hit to your retirement like the
last downturn when the S&P dropped 50%
you should have some precious metals in
your portfolio diversify make sure that
you are not at the whim of the rest of
the world's events or central banks in
various countries around the globe hedge
against inflation hedge against
uncertainty and instability with
precious metals the folks I use are the
folks over at Birch gold their feet
they're people that I trust people I
think are really good at their jobs
Birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau if you look back
historically when the bottom falls out
of everything else Gold does tend to
safeguard savings contact Birch gold
group
get a free information kit on physical
precious metals see if diversifying into
gold and silver makes sense for you
their comprehensive 16-page kit reveals
how gold and silver can protect your
savings they can legally move your IRA
or 401k out of stocks and bonds and into
a precious metals IRA if that's
something you're into to get your no
cost and no obligation kit text Ben 247
and 4747 again text Ben my name too 47
47 47 text Ben - 47 47 47 ok so Israel
had its second election in like eight
months yesterday and that followed
another election just a few months ago
in which an impasse was created after
Benjamin Netanyahu apparently had a
majority bloc formed and a man named
Avigdor Lieberman who was his former
defense minister and actually a former
member of his own party we could he took
his party the Israel bite a new party
and basically refused to form a
coalition with Netanyahu so long as
Netanyahu was in his words pandering
toward the religious parties in Israel
so there are several competing cross
currents in Israeli politics you know in
the United States abroad
buddy tends to think that Israeli
politics is mainly and centrally about
policy toward the Palestinian Authority
or policy toward Europe or policy toward
the United States and that simply is not
true in much the same way that policy in
the United States and politics in the
United States are largely not about
foreign policy and in the United States
most of the stuff we think about is
domestic policy in Israel most of the
stuff that people think about is
domestic policy specifically because
there is a widespread consensus ever
since the Second Intifada of 2000 2001
there's a widespread consensus that
there is no peace to be negotiated with
a bunch of terrorists which of course is
true and this is the dirty little secret
of Israeli politics that the press seems
to want to ignore that dirty little
secret is that even if Benjamin
Netanyahu does not end up as Prime
Minister of Israel there is no world in
which there are bilateral negotiations
with the Palestinian Authority ending
with a peace deal it's not a thing
that's going to happen Kovalev on the
blue and white party in israel which is
led by a former IDF chief-of-staff named
Bennigan's okay who right now
the Europeans are attempting to try him
for war crimes or somesuch because if
you ever served in the Israeli military
the Europeans will try to try you for
war crimes Bennigan's is not going to
fundamentally shift Israeli foreign
policy he may shift domestic policy with
regard to economics Bibi has been
Netanyahu has been a liberalizing Prime
Minister in terms of trying to free the
economy he has also worked hand in glove
with a lot of the religious parties and
this is another competing cross-current
in israel so they're a bunch of domestic
competing cross currents in Israeli
politics as I mentioned one is he is
economic the foundations of the State of
Israel are socialistic if you go back to
the foundation of the State of Israel it
was founded on the Socialist ideal
people lived on kyboot scene which were
basically communes that fell apart
Israel has been moving in a more
capitalist direction ever since which is
why it is one of the world's tech
leaders now which is why there are a lot
of companies that are based in Israel it
is leaps and bounds ahead of a lot of
other countries on a per capita basis in
terms of technological developments in
education that is because of a
liberalisation of the economy but there
is a significant and huge social welfare
state in the State of Israel and that's
been a source of tension in the State of
Israel and then another major source of
tension has been the religious versus
the secular in Israel so the state was
founded by secular zionists of people
who believed that there needed to be a
home
and for Jews to keep them safe but
weren't particularly religious didn't
have a lot of relationship with
traditional Jewish religion and then
there's a big block of people living in
Israel who are very religious and
there's all sorts of conflict over
public laws like for example should the
buses run on Shabbat should the buses
run on Sabbath the religious say no why
are we publicly funding buses to run on
the Jewish day of rest it is a Jewish
state and secular Israelis saying right
it's a state for the Jews it's a Jewish
state where Jews are supposed to be safe
but it is not a Jewish state in terms of
ritual law okay so that's one area of
conflict a smaller one a bigger one is
whether the so-called high redeem the
the media called them ultra-orthodox but
basically it is a sect of Orthodox
Judaism whether whether the HAR a deem
should serve in the military because the
military is overwhelmingly secular a lot
of the the HAR a deem say they don't
want to serve in the military and so
they get some sort of religious
exemption now on a personal level I'm
not in favor of the religious exemption
on a personal level my belief is that if
you if a secular Israeli is serving in
the military then a religious Israeli
should serve in the military that
everybody should serve in the military
in Israel and there are things called
Hestia Russia vote where there are a
bunch of Orthodox Jews who do serve in
the military in Israel and that should
become the model in Israel this sort of
religious Zionist movement and that's a
powerful movement in Israel but the
conflict between the the more orthodox
parties and the secular parties broke
out into the open a couple of years ago
within the last couple of years has been
Benjamin Netanyahu's coalition in Israel
on a two-party system it's a multi-party
system you have to have a bunch of
parties that form a majority and they
all have to get together and then they
have to form a majority of the Knesset
in order to govern
BB's Coalition has been formed with the
help of the so called right-wing parties
as well as with the religious parties so
that would be parties like you Sorrell
betánia which is a secular but
right-wing party particularly when it
comes to foreign policy as well as
parties like Shas or u t.j united
towards judaism which are the religious
parties and vote largely based on
religious concerns and subsidies to
religious communities and and all of
that so you saw Batum you decided
Avigdor Lieberman who has a real dislike
for Bibi Netanyahu there's a significant
personality clash between the two of
them and that is partially because
Netanyahu has a long history of
basically stymie
the growth efforts of people with Emily
could so one of the weird things about
Israeli politics also is that a lot of
the other parties in Israeli politics
were started by people who are castoffs
from oblique hood in other words people
who wanted to succeed Netanyahu and
Netanyahu wasn't making room for them
because in in Israel very often the
leadership of the party sort of moves on
to make room for the up and comers so
you have a bunch of people who are
outside of Likud now outside of
Netanyahu's party who started their own
parties because Netanyahu was not really
allowing them a path to to power so that
include a yellow check a dye yellow
check aid is a very and she's been noted
in the foreign media because she's very
attractive she also happens to be a
brilliant lawyer she was justice
minister under Benjamin Netanyahu and
now she is the head of a different party
and she's the she's the head of another
right-wing party that has also led by
enough holly bennett who also used to be
a member of Likud I believe and then you
uh Pentagon so I believe also used to be
a member of liquid leaning kovalev on
and you have a big door Lieberman who
used to be a member of the coudé leading
the East Earl battey no so Bibi has
maintained power at the expense of
kicking out or forcing out or convincing
people to leave moving them out of Likud
and this has led to an erosion in the
size and umbrella status of the coudé
but it has led to Bibi Netanyahu being
able to maintain power with the series
of coalition government so anyway a
couple of years ago
avi jor Lieberman basically made it
clear that he and Netanyahu were
significantly at odds and he was not
going to sit in a government that was
led by Netanyahu okay so it looked as
though Netanyahu might kind of deal with
Lieberman and the deal was going to be
that he was going to force the religious
groups with which he was already in a
coalition he's gonna force those groups
to do things they didn't want to do he
might think about trying to push some of
them into more military service or
cutting subsidies or any of that sort of
stuff and Lieberman was pushing very
hard for that Netanyahu said no and so
the government fell apart there's an
election and and Lieberman was still the
kingmaker in feature lieberman is a
clever political player he was still the
kingmaker because basically you had two
blocks inside of israeli politics you
had Likud and the right-wing parties in
the religious parties and then you had
blue and white which the media are
calling center-left but it really is not
a central Left Party it's it's sort of a
slightly to the left of Li coup
party a central left party would have
been in the old days labor but labor is
no longer really even a player it's kind
of amazing blue and white with the rest
of the left and the Arab parties a
twenty percent of Israel's population is
Arab and Muslim which again goes to the
idea that that Israel's an apartheid
state the third largest party in the
Knesset is a Muslim Arab party right the
joint list okay so that other bloc also
had like 55 seats and Lieberman was the
kingmaker
well Bibi had a coalition he could have
formed with Lieberman but they couldn't
cut a deal so Bibi called new elections
this was the second round of the
elections and they result in exactly the
same situation
it's a Bibi ends up with basically 56
seats in the right-wing coalition the
center-left and in joint lists end up
with 55 seats or 56 seats the results
are still coming in in this in in their
coalition and Lieberman ends up being
the swing so there's a lot of talk about
how exactly all of this ends up right it
does it end up that Lieberman sides with
the center left and the joint list does
he side instead with Netanyahu and the
and the religious parties and they
somehow find a way to bridge that gap or
do they do a Lieberman wants what
Lieberman wants is he wants to be seen
as the kingmaker and what they call a
unity government a unity government is
where people from across the aisle come
together and then they just form a broad
coalition for purposes of governing and
what he wants is for qahal the LaVon
which is Netanyahu's chief rivals to
join a coalition government with
Netanyahu's Likud and Lieberman holding
them together and that would be an
extremely strong majority right because
if you have blue and white Kovalev on
which has I think 32 seats and you have
liquid which also has 32 seats or 33 and
you add those together as 55 and then
you have Lieberman on top of that you
know 64 you can add in you can add in
another bunch of seats from probably the
the right wing I yell at Czech aid
Naftali Bennett party you end up with
probably well over 70 seats I have a
unity got now the problem with the unity
government is it's kind of fragile right
because people don't get along so well
right they don't have a lot of shared
political priorities so again three
options on the table
Lieberman joins the central left and the
Arab party to create a majority
coalition that's not going to happen so
the media are invested in the idea
that's gonna happen it's not going to
happen king lieberman is not joining a
coalition with the muslim arab party
joint list in Israel the reason being
members of that party the parties that
formed that joint it's called the joint
list cuz it used to be a bunch of
smaller parties that I'll join together
to create a joint list right those
parties have openly in the past called
for the destruction of the State of
Israel Lieberman is a hawk on security
that it would be like John Bolton
joining a coalition with Ilhan Omar it's
not going to happen
Avigdor Lieberman is not joining a
majority coalition with the joint list
and he has said so okay it's not me
saying that to the door Lieberman saying
that the media cuz they hate Netanyahu
so much they keep acting as the
Lieberman is going to join that
coalition and cast Netanyahu completely
out of power that is not a thing that's
going to happen okay so the other two
possibilities are that Lieberman joins
the right-wing coalition because in
Netanyahu pays him off with something
Ryan Netanyahu gives him a particularly
juicy post he puts a bunch of members of
the of Easter albeit a new into the
government in various posts he makes
concessions to use throughout bait a new
with regard to the religious parties and
Lieberman is able to pry out of
Netanyahu what he wasn't able to pry out
of Netanyahu before and Netanyahu
remains prime minister or alternatively
you ends up with a rotating prime
ministership and there wasn't talk about
this after the last election that
basically you would end up with almost
what the founders envisioned when they
had the president elected as the person
with the most vote and the vice
president became the second most voted
person and he Oded up with this weird
government where Thomas Jefferson was
serving in in John Adams his
administration it's kind of like that
you and ends up with Ben Egan's as part
time prime minister and you'd end up
Bibi Netanyahu as part time prime
minister and Lieberman is the power
broker between the two those are the two
available choices and if none of those
choices happen we get another election
and they just keep doing this thing
until they form a coalition so that is
where things sit the way the media are
playing this as big loss for Bibi
Netanyahu except I'm not sure that
Netanyahu really thought that things
were gonna radically change from the
last election cycle in fact the best
thing for Bibi Netanyahu is for Bibi
Netanyahu probably to enter the unity
government now I don't know if Netanyahu
believes that Netanyahu may believe that
his best path is to continue to maintain
power by cutting a deal with Lieberman
and Lieberman is going to exact a heavy
price in order to make that happen
there's been a lot of talk in Israel
about whether Netanyahu's relationship
with Trump didn't pay off to his benefit
that he was saying that he's super tight
with Trump and that the Israeli public
basically like well it doesn't have to
be you it could be Bennigan's
negotiating with Trump also he had
mentioned the possibility of a joint
defense pact and Trump had not come
through with anything like that in the
days leading up to the election there
was there was this idea that maybe he'd
undermine Netanyahu Jerusalem Post was
talking about that I don't think that's
really the case I think the people are
just frustrated that Netanyahu didn't
form a government last time and so they
voted exactly the same way this time
that they did last time which makes
sense if weari helped the vote of 2016
in 2017 it would probably look a lot
like a voter 2016 so that is where
things currently lie I think that the
most likely outcome probably is the
unity government I think that that would
be the smartest thing for a Netanyahu to
do because Netanyahu is currently under
the possibility of indictment he can't
be indicted well he is the sitting Prime
Minister so so long as he is the sitting
Prime Minister rotating powers
Bennigan's it's not bad for him plus
let's be real about this Pentagon's who
is this general the head of the Kovalev
on the blue and white party Bennigan's
is an enigma wrapped in a mystery
wrapped in a riddle nobody knows
anything about him they know sort of his
military background he's a lot like a
lot of other former Israeli leaders who
have a military background but they've
kept their politics pretty hidden that
be people like it's khakhra bean who
ended up on the left and include Barak
was also an IDF chief-of-staff lends it
up on the left it would also include
people like Arielle sharone who ended up
on the right but not in Euros right as
people thought he was gonna be who was a
general in the Israeli army Israel has a
habit of electing high-ranking military
men to positions of power because Israel
is constantly in a tenuous international
situation with regard to security but if
the Israeli public see a rotating prime
ministership between Bibi and and Benny
gods or shared power arrangement between
the two of them it's pretty obvious
who's going to win that public relations
battle Benny God's is not good at this
they've been hiding Benny God's
basically behind a tree this whole
election cycle and Benny Gon's has said
five words maybe for the entire election
cycle so if he actually ends up in power
it's good I do not think that that is a
long-lasting arrangement now the other
possibility is that the Likud actually
ousts Netanyahu in order to cut a deal
with Lieberman right that is the that is
sort of the out-of-left-field
possibility is that the internal Likud
battle takes
waise and somebody else like a
second-tier person there there are a few
names that are floating around ends up
taking over the leadership of Li coud he
cuts a deal with Lieberman he ends up
becoming the next prime minister what
does this mean for foreign policy the
answer for foreign policies doesn't mean
a hell of a lot really it does not mean
a hell of a lot because again there's a
widespread Israeli consensus Iran wants
to murder us Hezbollah wants to murder
us Hamas wants to murder us right this
is what Israelis think and the Europeans
don't like us and Trump's our friend and
we're not cutting a deal with a bunch of
terrace wanna murder us right that is
the the internal Israeli consensus over
there
so that's not changing whether
Bennigan's ends up in power or whether
Netanyahu ends up in power and it's
going to be a widespread surprise to the
left when Bennigan's ends up basically
governing like Bibi Netanyahu would on
foreign policy and it'll be it'll be
fascinating to see how they react to
that frankly because they've always
posed it is that Bibi Netanyahu is the
obstacle to peace in the Middle East the
obvious truth is that it is all the
terrorists that surround us around
Israel that are the obstacle to peace in
the Middle East and then what I predict
what you'll see is the media turn on the
Israeli public and suggest that the
Israeli public is the real obstacle so
it's no longer in it's in Yahoo it's no
longer bunny guns it's all the people
who'll elect these people if only they
would elect they'd bring back the merits
party if only they bring back shell
Amash of if then bring back the peace
now party from the mid 90s then
everything would be healed and be all
better the media have a vested interest
in trying to portray the
israel-palestinian conflict as Israel's
fault it is a bunch of crap it has
always been a bunch of crap they will
continue to press that forward they've
tried to blame it on Netanyahu so they
can avoid the baseline reality which is
that the Israeli public are not going to
make concessions to terrorists but I
think they're soon to be disabused of
the notion that this is just a Netanyahu
policy this is an Israeli policy
Israelis are not cutting deals with
Mahmoud Abbas is terrorists Palestinian
Authority or Hamas or Islamic Jihad or
Hezbollah they're not doing any of those
things okay coming up in a second we'll
talk about Mike Pompeo who's heading to
the Middle East to figure out Iran
strategy first let's talk about the
importance of a business card so I go to
a lot of events and people are
constantly trying to have any business
cards I will admit that just like any
other human being I'm affected by the
look of a business card if it looks
cheap like you printed it out from
goes very likely it ends up in the
washing machine in my pocket of my jeans
if however it is a nice business card
there's a better shot that I end up
handing it over to my assistant Katelyn
who's wonderful by the way and she ends
up putting it in the rolodex well you
could be getting a nice business card
that really makes an impression from
vistaprint your next big opportunity is
coming right now all it takes to feel
like you're ready to own the now is 10
bucks for 10 bucks Vistaprint gives you
500 personalized cards with exactly the
look that you want that is a low price
to make a lasting impression and because
you can choose the colors fonts designs
images well that means you can create
something as unique and compelling as
your business I mean really make a first
impression as I say you give a nice
business card you are going to standout
vistaprint wants you to be able to own
the nail in any situation and that's why
our listeners will get free shipping on
all business cards any style any
quantity just go to vistaprint.com
enter promo code Shapiro - for free
shipping on all business cards any style
any quantity this is a limited time
offer on the now at vistaprint.com promo
code Shapiro - that's promo code Shapiro
followed by the number two you support
our show when you support our sponsors
go check out vistaprint.com right now
use that promo code Shapiro - okay so
Mike Pompeo meanwhile is headed over to
the Middle East to figure out Iran's
strategy it's unclear the Iran strategy
that is actually being pursued at this
point as I say yesterday I think that
the actual foreign policy of the United
States is was and kind of always will be
muddled through because the American
people aren't interested in empire
building I think correctly so the
American people are also not interested
in full-scale isolationism because every
time the United States gets isolationist
we get a Pearl Harbor or 9/11 so we end
up kind of being mildly reactive
yeah we're present in the world we have
bases all over the place we have a
strong military and we can react to
threats but we don't want long-term
occupations or invasions we're not into
that sort of thing and so what happens
when there's a hot spot like Iran tends
to be the possibility of a flare-up and
then it kind of recedes Iran is is the
is the herpes outbreak of the Middle
East the Iranian government may flare up
and then they sort of recede so Mike
Pompeo is trying to create a policy
right now
The Washington Post reporting that the
Trump administration has announced that
Pompeo would fly to the Persian Gulf on
Wednesday to discuss a response to an
attack on Saudi
facilities as 'iron Supreme Leader ruled
out any direct talks with the United
States
Pompeyo spur-of-the-moment trip which
will include stops in Saudi Arabia and
the UAE underscores the danger the
tensions with Iran could spiral into
military conflict president Trump has
said Iran was probably responsible for
the attack that he would like to avoid a
war
Pompeyo has assigned blame more directly
now Trump obviously obviously does not
wish for there to be a war with Iran at
this point is why I've suggested that
the likeliest solution here is that the
United States pledges to strengthen the
defense of Saudi Arabia without pledging
any sort of aggressive aggressive action
against Iran I think that's probably the
happy medium where the u.s. ends up we
maybe end up helping flag some tankers
in the Straits of Hormuz and guiding
those tankers through the Straits of
Hormuz against the possibility of
Iranian aggression re-establishing some
sense of deterrence the weekend attack
which the United States says it believes
originated in Iran despite claims by
rebels in Yemen that they carried it out
appears to have dashed all hope that
Trump might meet with Iranian president
Hassan rouhani at the UN General
Assembly in New York while the Iranians
I don't think were all that interested
in face-to-face meetings with Trump I
think they're more interested in
pressuring the Europeans to break with
Trump and undermine the jcpoa the the
revocation of the of the Iran nuclear
deal
the Europeans want to surrender to Iran
okay it is pretty much that simple the
Europeans want Iran to get their money
they want Iran to be part of the world
economy and they don't care if we're on
spreads terrorism all over the Middle
East they simply don't care because they
figure the u.s. is gonna flip the bill
anyway if something goes wrong which
unfortunately has been European foreign
policy since basically the late Cold War
you know the fact that that Trump and
what when Trump says that the Europeans
have not paid their share of their fair
share for defense that is technically
true I mean the United States basically
footed the bill for all of European
defense for several decades during the
Cold War and that allowed them to live
high on the hog in terms of social
welfare programs well Europe can pursue
that policy again but there will be some
tragic consequences to that policy and
you're starting by the way to see those
consequences in terms of the outbreak of
nationalist sentiments in Europe largely
driven by the increase in in unvetted
Muslim refugees coming from the Middle
East into the heart of Europe and
creating all sorts of social schisms and
the
Ronn supreme leader ayatollah khomeini
said all the officials in the islamic
republic unanimously believe there will
be no negotiations at any level with the
united states again they're trying to
pressure the Europeans this is not about
the United States at this point I think
that the way this ends probably is with
the United States trying to trying to
strengthen shore up Saudi defenses
without getting involved in a conflict
okay meanwhile there's a new NBC Wall
Street Journal poll out Joe Biden
continues to lead the 2020 Democratic
field Elizabeth Warren continues to
steal support from Bernie Sanders so
she's not actually taking support from
Joe Biden
she's taking support from Bernie Sanders
and sooner or later Sanders is gonna
have to open up the guns see if these
poll results are real sooner or later
Bernie Sanders is going to have to go to
war with her so this was the question as
I said last week before the last debate
there was basically a Mexican standoff
like at the end of good the bad the ugly
in which Joe Biden was pointing his guns
at Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren
and Warren was pointing at Sanders and
Biden and Sanders are pointing at Warren
and Biden but nobody wanted to fire cuz
if you're the first person to fire you
lose that was the basic rule is a
reservoir dog standoff scenario it was
it was Joe Biden wanted to watch
Elizabeth and Bernie go to war and wreck
each other and Warren wanted Sanders and
Biden to go to war and wreck each other
and Biden and they'll want the other two
to go to war right Sanders wants war and
in Biden to go to war and wreck each
other that was the basic math but if
Elizabeth Warren starts stealing away
enough support from Bernie Sanders he's
not gonna have a choice but he has to
wreck her because he's hoping that if he
wrecks her then maybe those people come
back flooding to him and if he sits
still he's out of the race so we'll get
to those poll results in just one second
first let's talk about how hard it is to
create healthy habits you know when you
are trying to get in the habit of
working out every day trying to get in
the habit of eating healthy and people
talk about diets but diets end up being
yo-yo kind of things where you go on the
die and then you get off the diet and it
ain't great or you start exercising
because you're really enthusiastic and
like a week later you're not
enthusiastic anymore and you stop that I
well this is why you need new Numa is
fantastic it is an app that helps you
change yourself helps you change your
approach to fitness and health they help
you achieve specific goals not just
losing weight and then they will they
will it's not just a nutrition app that
helps you calorie count though it is
that it will give you psychological tip
to help you overcome the whatever is
weighing on you today so you can duck
gets on what you need to get done and
gives you informational techniques about
the kinds of food and how they're
processed it is just fantastic i've been
using new my wanted to lose about five
pounds I have taken off two five pounds
that's why I look so ripped and chiseled
lately that is because of new newman's a
habit changing solution that helps users
learn to develop a new relationship with
food through personalized courses
Newman's not a diet it's a healthy easy
to stick to way of life you don't have
to change it all in one day
small steps that's where the big
progress is made sign up for your trial
today at noon and oom calm Shapiro what
do you have to lose visit Noom comm
slash capiro start your trial today
that's n oom comm / Shapiro it's the
last weight loss program you will need
NUMA comm / Pierrot I've actually
recommended it to my parents it really
is fantastic ok so here are the latest
poor results there are two new polls out
they both show Joe Biden up they both
show Bernie Sanders down that is the
trend so there's there have been let's
see four polls taken since the debates
last week and two of them have Biden up
a lot larger and two of them have Biden
up a lot smaller so there's a political
morning consult poll that came out
yesterday and the polling period was
let's see today is the 18th so the
polling period would have been Saturday
through Monday and that polling that
that poll the political morning console
poll showed Biden with 32 Sanders with
20 Warren with 18
so basically Biden way ahead and warned
in Sanders neck-and-neck there's a
survey USA poll same basic period and it
shows Biden at 33 Warren at 19
Bernie at 17 so we're in ahead of Bernie
but still close then there is the NBC
news/wall Street Journal poll and this
is the one that has got to have Bernie
Sanders in a panic it has Joe Biden up
at 31 Elizabeth Warren at 25 and Bernie
Sanders at 14 in other words the media
attention on Elizabeth Warren is driving
people from Bernie Sanders over to
Elizabeth Warren
now I had suggested that last week's
debate was a blown opportunity for war
and that if she wanted to make a strong
move then she would have to at some
point go after Biden that she's figuring
if she buys her time it'll be okay I
still think that she blew an opportunity
I think that she receded into the field
but it is also true that she's becoming
the default not
did not Sanders candidate and that is
something right I mean just being there
and being the person who is not slow
moderate Gaffey Joe and also not being
bluntly crazy son buzz it's a thing it's
a thing there's room for that being
progressive enough for some of the
Sanders people but being not crazy
enough for some of the Weiden people
it's not a bad place to be is it enough
for her to win the primaries I don't
know because again she has no black
support like none none whatsoever
and she's received just funning media
attention absolutely fawning the New
York Times fawning over the fact that
she brought out several thousand people
to Central Park in New York yesterday
and Donald Trump rightly pointing out to
the media guys like if you stop in the
middle of 42nd Avenue in New York Street
in New York City there are like a
thousand people there if you can't draw
a crowd in New York City you suck at
politics right Kamala Harris threw like
10,000 20,000 people to her lead off in
Sacramento so drawing a big crowd has
Mitt Romney learned at the end of the
2012 election does not mean that you're
going to win an election Trump is right
about that with that said there are two
polls both of them show Warren up over
Sanders now NBC News Wall Street Journal
Biden 31 Warren 25 Sanders 14 economists
YouGov this one has always been very
favorable to Elizabeth Warren actually
the last time they did this poll this
economist YouGov poll
it showed Biden and Warren basically
even so she's actually dropped a little
bit in this poll from what I see Biden
at 26 Warren at 21 Sanders at 14 so that
means that she's closed within striking
distance of Biden but she would have to
convince half of Sanders his support to
move over to her and I wonder if that's
the case I do wonder if that's the case
because it seems to me that the Bernie
bros the people love Bernie they got to
be looking at Warren and saying this is
she's a phony she's a fraud
and there's not someone sufficiently
committed to our Communist way of life
and I think that there will become a
it's still very early there will come a
point somewhere in here where Warren
starts to earn some negative media
attention it happens to every candidate
they got their ups and their downs she
started with a real bad down with the
I'm Native American oh wait no I'm not
that was real bad and then she's had a
consistent uptick in media energy and
attention and in and sic a fan think
coverage directed at her for months and
that's led to this increasing a steady
rise I just post some of the other
candidates who that Upton is like baito
started here and just went directly down
I mean that was Beto's candidacy
Elizabeth Warren starts down and is been
trending up but it's still early there's
still room for people to go after
Elizabeth Warren even Stephen Colbert
was tempted to do that last night he
asked her about the whole you know you
keep saying that you're not gonna raise
taxes on the middle class or you avoid
the question and you're avoiding the
question there hasn't been medicare for
all before you keep being asked in the
debates how are you gonna pay for it are
you gonna raise the middle-class taxes
right how are you gonna pay for it are
so here's how we're going to do this
costs are going to go up for the
wealthiest Americans for big corporation
taxes which will be my cost and
hard-working middle-class families are
going to see their costs go down and all
their taxes go up well but here's the
thing here's the thing I've listened to
these answers a few times before okay
and then he keeps saying like good for
Steven I've never said these words
before good for Steven Colbert so Steven
is kind of Colbert is basically a Bernie
bro Stephen Colbert asking for a very
straight question and not getting a
straight answer eventually this is gonna
come back to haunt Elizabeth Warren
there is this image of her as this
pristine progressive and such nonsense
she is just as phony as khamel Harris
she's just better at it and I think that
the progressive left is gonna wake up to
this and when that happens there's gonna
be a virulent reaction and there will be
an intern a scene war between Shaw but
not between Joe Biden between Elizabeth
Warren and between Bernie Sanders that
internation war is coming
now Bernie you remember Bernie actually
did the same routine with Hillary
Clinton early in the primaries early in
the primary said I don't care about
hadam emails and then by the end of the
race he was like you remember those
emails guys remember that that was weird
right Bernie Sanders steered clear of
Hillary until it became clear he could
not steer clear of Hillary any more well
you're gonna see the same thing happened
with Elizabeth Warren he went on the
view and he was like Elizabeth from my
own good friends we've been good friends
for 20 years
at a certain point he's gonna start
flinging pudding at her yeah think this
chocolate pudding and that that's the
way the
is going to go because it can't go any
other way I mean if he starts to lose
support who the hell is gonna go after
Joe Biden really there's no case for
that now in a second we're gonna talk
about the great hope for Elizabeth
Warren and it lies not in stealing
Bernie Sanders his support but in
finishing Joe Biden because again Joe
Biden's base of support is heavily
minority a lot of black voters really
like Joe Biden why well because he is
stapled to Barack Obama's pant leg and
he is the chicken who crossed the road
right brock obama was the chicken who
crossed the road and joe biden is the is
the person stapled to the chicken's pant
leg i mean that is that is what happened
here joe biden is a hanger-on he's
always been a hanger-on but that's not a
bad place to be with black voters in the
United States among whom Barack Obama is
still extraordinarily popular we'll get
to Joe Biden in just one second first
let's talk about your sleep quality so
I'm on the road you know what that means
I'm not sleeping as well as I would were
I at home not just because my wife is
not here but also because the quality of
my bed is not as good I'm staying in a
nice hotel but let me tell you my
mattress at home way more comfortable
why because I'm using helix sleep helix
sleep has a quiz it takes two minutes to
complete it matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you no matter how you sleep
on your side on your back whether you're
a hot sleeper whatever helix can make
just what your body needs just go to
helix sleep calm slash men take their
two minutes leave quiz they will match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life as
I say I cannot wait to get home right
now specifically because I need some
sleep and helix is gonna make it happen
for couples helix can even split that
mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side they've got a
10 year warranty you get to try it out
for 100 nights risk-free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you will helix is offering up to 125
bucks off all mattress orders for our
listeners get up to 125 bucks off at
helix sleep calm squash Ben that's helix
sleep calm slash Ben for up to 125 bucks
off your mattress order helix sleep calm
slash Ben go check them out right now
okay in just a second we'll get to Joe
Biden and the and the only attack that
matters on Joe Biden
yeah we'll get to that in just once I
will also get to Cory Lewandowski really
going at it with the House Judiciary
Committee Democrats for some good and
some ill we'll get to that in one second
first you have to go over to Daley wire
calm and subscribe if you do that you
spend $9.99 a month or 99 bucks a year
you got the rest
of this show live you also get two
additional hours with me every single
day on video on demand without
commercials you get all of that you also
get me Michael Moore's show if that's
the thing that you want don't know why
you what but we have Matt wall she's
great and we also have Andrew Clavin who
is mediocre so we have a lot of mediocre
to great and one one bad host you can
check all of that out simply by
subscribing over at daily wire.com and
$99 ear also gets you that's the very
greatest in beverage vessels of course
the leftist ears hot or cold tumbler
refilling it daily it is magical and as
I say we have deactivated the cloaking
device because I want you to see it so
we can advertise it but normally when
we're on the road it actually disappears
it's pretty incredible so go check us
out over at daily wire.com we're the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so as I've now been saying for several
weeks there are two lines of attack on
Joe Biden that have been used one is
that he's old and we keep seeing him
gaff so for example he said yesterday
that the child tax credit that he's
pushing could put seven hundred and
twenty million women back in the
workforce which is weird stat
considering there are 330 million people
in the United States so I'm not sure
where he's coming up with the other four
hundred million people and why all of
them are women is this a weird Joe Biden
fantasy who knows a lot of shoulders to
rub their butt job is that sort of stuff
gonna hurt Joe Biden no that's not gonna
hurt you Biden because again we all know
he's slow Joe when he gaffes all that
he's been Gavin for years right he was
called Uncle Joe because he was the he
was the kind of dopey uncle at the
Thanksgiving party who would have one
too many beers and stumble into the den
while you're watching football and knock
over the chips right that's who uncool
Joe was when he was Uncle Joe now he's
just Grampa Joe and he can't stumble
into the room anymore and knock over the
chips he basically just sort of conked
out on me on the 1970 zero recliner with
his feet up and his shoes off right
that's Joe Biden now I say in a general
election I don't think that hurts him I
mean I think that a return to normalcy
even if the normalcy is just basically a
comatose human being that's not a
horrible pitch but in a primary it ain't
gonna help them too much but at the same
time it's not gonna hurt him too much we
all know who he is you know they they
keep pretending the gaffe upon gaffe
upon gaffe upon I promise you Elizabeth
Warren's gaffes it seems like far bigger
than a gaffe that she just keeps lying
about whether she's gonna raise
middle-class taxes it seems like that
that's out that's not a gaffe that's
like an actual policy fail for Elizabeth
Warren so you know I don't think that's
gonna hurt him the second line of attack
on Joe Biden is that he has to be
cancelled and this one again I have a
hard time believing that this is going
to hurt him simply because the nature of
the messengers carrying the attack are
not capable of hurting him so Kamala
Harris briefly hurt Joe Biden when she
went to the you didn't want forced
busing even though she didn't want
forced busing and nobody wanted forced
busing in the 1970s and she briefly hurt
him with the and you were hanging out
with segregationist and he was like no
they're just senators and I was working
with them and some of them are bad
people and I said so she briefly heard
him because she had the credibility to
speak on the issue because
our era of identity politics a white
person saying that's a Joe Biden has no
impact a black candidate saying that to
Joe Biden has some impact and then her
poll numbers started to drop in his
started to rise again and he wasn't
supremely damaged by any of that
Elizabeth Warren playing that card and
could have any sort like that that ain't
gonna work at all
Elizabeth Warren is whiter than the
backside of this piece of paper I mean
she is as white as snow Elizabeth Warren
is whiter than I am and that is pretty
damned white I mean I clap on
one-in-three gang I mean she is she she
is very white and so her going after
Biden's base of support is likely
unavailing and so instead what you're
seeing is some of the so-called opinion
journalists in the media some of the
professor's of history going after Joe
Biden on her behalf I hoping that if
they knock him down that she will rise
up again I don't I don't think that that
is likely to work particularly well but
they're gonna try Marcia Chad Elaine is
the distinguished associate professor of
history at Georgetown University and she
has a piece in The Washington Post today
called Joe Biden isn't the only Democrat
who is blamed black America for its
problems
she says former Vice President Joe Biden
spent Sunday at the 16th Street Baptist
Church in Birmingham Alabama speaking on
the anniversary of a bombing there that
killed four black girls the candidate
has had some trouble handling issues
involving race after conceding that
institutional segregation and redlining
banks exist Biden veered away from a
logic that might have called for some
strands of reparative justice instead he
turns the old liberal playbook castigate
black families look he started you talk
about education after rightly suggesting
higher wages for teachers and more
funding for schools with title one
designation Biden reminded listeners the
teachers a profession that his majority
white cannot do it alone they have he
said every problem coming to them and
the way to improve outcomes in
segregated schools would be simply to
send social workers to visit black
families to teach them how to raise
their children better complete with the
record player on at night to expose kids
to more words while Biden was criticized
roundly for that answer it fit quite
neatly into the grand American political
tradition of evading serious
conversation about the legacy of slavery
by expressing displeasure with the
victims of it well I'm sorry if you
knock up a woman and then leave that is
not you being a victim of slavery that's
you being a bad person I mean that no
the answer is no you don't get to blame
the personal decision
you may have a child out of wedlock with
a person with whom you were not married
on slavery because you were not enslaved
if that person was not enslaved their
parents were not enslaved their
grandparents were not enslaved their
great-grandparents were likely not
enslaved their great-great grandparents
maybe we're enslaved probably you're
talking about their great great great
grandparents okay so no you don't get to
do that so but I guess the idea is that
if Joe Biden suggests that if you are
going to you know prosecute criminality
or encourage parents to spend more time
on education in the home or encourage
parents to stay married that this is the
vestiges of slavery of victim-blaming I
don't think that I don't think that dog
hunts but I think that the left would
like for that dog donned and so they're
gonna continue pushing that we'll see if
the Democratic Party Falls for it I have
my doubts about that
so predictions I think that Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie Sanders will go to war
in quite short order and I think that
Joe Biden is gonna sit this one out and
I think that Joe Biden will probably
benefit from that war at least a little
bit okay meanwhile there was a big
hearing yesterday at the House Judiciary
Committee Democrats called corey
lewandowski why well when Corey
Lewandowski was an aide to Donald Trump
Trump according to the Mullen report
called on Corey Lewandowski to deliver a
letter to Jeff Sessions basically firing
him for not firing robert muller and
Lewandowski conveniently just didn't do
it right Corey Lewandowski was like
that's kind of a bad idea we're not
gonna do that and it was in the model
report there's talk about whether it
amounted to obstruction there's an
argument yes there's an I think a more
solid argument no although I definitely
see the argument for yes but it's all in
the report
Democrats can't let the Mallo report go
because the Moller report did not
recommend prosecution it didn't make any
recommendation at all and as it turns
out it would have been very difficult to
prove obstruction of justice on the
basis of the allegations that were made
in the Mullah report Democrats don't
even want to impeach on that basis and
Nancy Pelosi does not want to impeach on
the basis of the Mulla report Democrats
nonetheless have to prove their mettle
to their own supporters and so they
called forth Corey Lewandowski and went
really poorly for them because it turns
out that you know what Corey Lewandowski
is fantastic at grandstanding I mean
really great at it and Democrats were
sending mixed messages on the one hand
they were like you know Corey if you
delivered that letter that would have an
obstruction of justice that was really
bad on the other hand the llegará
chicken for not having delivered your
chicken for not having delivered
here is here's needles Cullen Steve
Cohen I call them needles because he
really he resembles in both face and
manner needles from back to the future -
trying to temp Marty McFly into a into a
game of chicken here's Steve Cohen
saying to corey lewandowski that he's a
chicken Steve cones I don't what his
thing with chicken is remember he
actually went to a press conference to
call somebody a chicken and he actually
brought along like a KFC container I
don't know what's the obsession with
chicken I don't get it here Steve Cohen
Donald Trump talk to you outside normal
channels so there'd be no record of
anything that he asked you to do to
obstruct justice
nothing to do with that at all the
president knew what he was doing was
wrong mr. sessions knew what he was
doing is wrong mr. McGann knew he's
doing wrong you seemed to the only
person didn't think was wrong but mr.
Trump was wrong just at the last minute
you got cold feet you chickened out
the president's trust was misplaced you
decided not to do what you told the
president you were going to do and you
handed it off to somebody else
yeah McFly a chicken you chicken
Lewandowski isn't gonna confess to
committing a crime like what would Steve
Cohen think he's doing this whole thing
ended up being a debacle
because Lewandowski basically just said
to Democrats you're not getting anything
else out of me so this is a waste of my
time here is Lewandowski talking to
Jerry Nadler the chairman of the House
Judiciary Committee saying why am I even
here this is stupid we as a nation would
be better served if elected officials
like yourself concentrated your efforts
to combat the true crises facing our
country as opposed to going down rabbit
holes like this hearing instead of
focusing on petty and personal politics
the committee focused on solving the
challenges of this generation imagine
how many people we could help or how
many lives we could save okay yeah that
so so Lewandowski doing that routine
it's not a bad routine so the good of
Corey Lewandowski is he did call out the
Democrats repeatedly for political
grandstanding and so Lewandowski
completely derailed the impeachment
hearing he just went after people with
hammer he wants to run for Senate in New
Hampshire so it's a it's a good
political moment for him here he is
pretty much fully during this impeded
this impeachment hearing mr. Lewandowski
is it correct that is reported in the
Mullen report on June 19 2017 you met
alone in the Oval Office with the
president
is there a book and page number you can
reference me to please I don't have a
copy of the report in front of me volume
2 page 90 could you read the exact
language of the report sir I don't have
it available to me I don't think I need
to do that and I have a limited time did
you meet alone with the president that
date congressman I'd like you to refresh
my memory by providing a copy the report
so I can follow along hey you don't have
a copy with I don't have a copy of the
report congressman chairman I requested
that the clock be stopped while this
charade is sorted out okay and then
Lewandowski went after Sheila
jackson-lee says she was she was in fact
ranting about how Trump is a criminal
and he was like why are you ranting at
me stop ranting at me is look it's
entertainment is it good
no I mean Corey Lewandowski was engaged
in bad activity with Trump I mean Trump
was in fact telling him to go fire
somebody in his administration because
he didn't like the investigation that
was being conducted now was he
attempting to obstruct them all or
investigation I mean not really cuz
Muller didn't find anything so that that
sort of goes to intent here as opposed
to Trump just being irritable and
volatile and saying things I mean that's
why again I say would be difficult to
prosecute I think that it probably
doesn't amount to obstruction because
you have to have intent to obstruct in
order to do that and Trump does have the
executive capacity to fire robert muller
or me he works for the executive branch
but here's Corey Lewandowski ripping
into Sheila jackson-lee we will expose
the truth be here to be telling the
truth I yield back the time of the
gentlelady has expired the witness may
answer the question I don't believe
there was a question congressman very
well yes there was could you repeat the
question out in here I'd be happy to
repeat the just a rant okay and that is
actually true I mean because all of
these House hearings are really stupid
the truth is when was the last time you
watched a House hearing and you were
like ah a new piece of information we
didn't know it's all grandstanding crap
now was it all good for Cory Lewandowski
no because the fact is that Corey
Lewandowski and the Trump administration
do engage in dishonesty fairly regularly
with the media so Cory Lewandowski was
act by a spy lawyer named Barry Burke
this is the new thing is that Democrats
are calling in lawyers to do the
questioning they suck at they call him
this lawyer Barry Burke and Barry Burke
plays a clip of Lewandowski on MSNBC
saying that he had never had any
communication about Rob
Moeller with Donald Trump and here's
Lewandowski being like yeah okay so I
lied what you gonna do about it what you
gonna do about it I don't ever remember
the president ever asking me to get
involved with Jeff Sessions or the
Department of Justice in any way she did
you hear that sir that was you saying on
MSNBC you don't ever remember the
president ever asking you to get
involved with Jeff Sessions or the
Department of Justice in any way shape
or form
that wasn't true was it sir I heard that
and that was not true was it I have no
obligation to be honest to the media
just because there's just as as honest
as anybody else
okay that is that is a hell of a lie now
here's the thing he's admitting to lying
right publicly lying but I think this is
it is kind of baked into the cake I mean
unfortunately this is the state of our
politics is that bad yeah it's bad it's
bad you shouldn't lie to the media at
the same time is it baked into the cake
politically speaking did this hurt Trump
in any way the answer is no and you
could see that the media were really
disappointed that it didn't an NBC
correspondent just came out and said
listen this hearing was a failure it was
a total fail insofar as this was an
effort to get a particular narrative out
today has been rocky yes I think it's
largely been a failure and I think it's
in part because Democrats have been more
interested in in getting their moment on
television of yelling at Corey
Lewandowski and making the point in
winning the argument rather than
patiently questioning him okay and that
of course is exactly true
it's exactly true and because everybody
feels like everything is a political
football these days nobody's gonna like
did anyone was anyone into the wild in
this impression that Corey Lewandowski
is like a deeply honest human being if
so I'm wondering why and why they would
be under that misimpression so it hurts
Democrats more than it hurts Republicans
but it just reinforces the fact that
Democrats are there to pander
Republicans are there to pander and
everything kind of sucks now meanwhile
the polarization of the American public
continues a pace with wokes Gold's doing
their best to ruin every aspect of
American life I'm very excited that
merriam-webster dictionary has now added
the non-binary pronoun vade to the
dictionary because when I look at a book
four definitions of words what I want is
a made-up definition of a word
that has never been used this way in all
of human history a plural noun used as a
singular noun to refer to a singular
gender wouldnt use a plural noun and
merriam-webster is gonna go along with
this which just demonstrates once and
for all that logic has gone out the
window
people are tailoring science to meet
politically correct demands people are
tailoring language to meet politically
correct demands merriam-webster
according to the Washington Post has
added a new definition of the word they
to its dictionary declaring the pronoun
may be used to refer to a single person
whose gender identity is non-binary they
according to the Washington Post is a
liberating pronoun for many non-binary
individuals what the hell is a
liberating pronoun how does a pronoun
liberate you were you in shackles and
then some once a day and now you're out
of the shackles and what kind of
nonsense is this for many Americans the
use of a as a singular pronoun can be
ungrammatical and confusing that would
not be for many Americans that would be
for all Americans unless you're talking
about the small group of sjw's who
decide we have to redefine all of
language in order to meet politically
correct demands it's it is insanity and
then you wonder why people like the same
people who demand truth truth absolute
truth we're the media and we want the
truth also they is a singular pronoun
not what now hmm obviously look honesty
has taken a backseat on all sides to
whatever is the political motivation of
the day this is just sort of an
encapsulating perfect example okay time
for a thing I like and then we'll do a
quick thing that I hate so things that I
like today I've mentioned Howard Zinn
before on the program for people who
have never read Howard Zinn's awful book
a people's history of the United States
which is basically a pastiche of
horrible things about the United States
taken out of context out of historical
context a history that basically paints
the United States the same as Nazi
Germany a history that suggests that the
United States is uniquely responsible
for every evil the world has ever seen
Howard Zinn was a garbage a garbage
historian and his book is terrible
there's a good book to bunking all of
Howard Zinn stupid ideas by Mary Graybar
the book is called debunking Howard Zinn
exposing the fake history the turn to
generation against America his book is
still a massive bestseller if you ever
watch Good Will Hunting
it's invoked as like the apotheon
of American history by the brilliant
Matt Damon character and that's how I
knew that Matt Damon was an idiot in
that film was because he said citing
Howard Zinn if you want to know what
Howard Zinn was namely a Marxist if you
want to know why his history is
incorrect just take a look at the book
American history does have shades
American history has good and it has bad
but according to Howard Zinn it was all
bad like every every aspect of it was
bad even the best parts were bad I mean
Howard Zinn spends a significant portion
of a people's history of the United
States explaining why Lincoln was bad
and why he didn't really want to free
the slaves I mean it's pretty
astonishing stuff but this book is good
debunking Howard Zinn go check it out
right now ok time for a quick thing that
I hate so Sean Spicer was on Dancing
with the Stars so I will admit that
Dancing with the Stars may in fact be
one of the things that I hate like I
think that this is just it is the apex
of American stupidity and maybe Western
stupidity generally I assume they like
the sort of thing in Europe as well I
mean if you've ever seen the Eurovision
concert there's a lot of them and that
is one but Dancing with the Stars which
is basically where we take a bunch of B
Lister's and then we try to prepare them
to dance and then we watch them it does
feel like the late days of Panem when
you watch Dancing with the Stars
in any case Sean Spicer the former White
House press secretary who was widely
derided for his his bizarre sort of
hostage videos from the White House
press secretary show where he would be
asked a question and he didn't want to
give the answer and so he would kind of
stare into the distance and try to blink
the answer in Morse code
in any case Sean Spicer who was ousted
pretty early on in the Trump
administration is now on Dancing with
the Stars and here is what it looked
like
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah well listen I will give it to Sean
Spicer it takes courage to wear that
shirt and to play the bongos and to
dance that is that is the thing that's
not actually thing I hate so the thing
that I hate is that all of this is
stupid but all of me come on the whole
thing is this intelligent television did
it make your life Cygnet no but of
course it's stupid that's the whole
point it's kitschy I get it it's kitschy
and it's fun Kitsch the left
went nuts how could you possibly treat
Sean Spicer like any other bila
celebrity after all this man ruined
United the same people by the way who
made Donald Trump into Donald Trump
right they took a man who was a b-list
celebrity in the 1990s and then turned
him back into an a-list celebrity in the
2000s with a kitschy reality show in
which he fired people are pretended to
fire people those same people are like
we can't humor Sean Spicer
we can't humor Sean Spicer the
Washington Post has a piece called
Dancing with the Stars perfected a
formula for kitschy Escapist joy cannot
survive today's politics critic Linda
Stasi snart of the premiere ABC must
have gone to the well or maybe that's
the cesspool and dredged up some of the
lowest level celebrities available in
the country today for this competition
show and but then the post had to run a
headline into dancing as a swinging
success because people were perfectly
willing to watch Dancing with the Stars
but they are very angry with Sean Spicer
on Monday's episode Spicer's on the lime
green shirt with ruffled sleeves and
performed a salsa - the Spice Girls his
spice up with your life with
professional partner Lindsey Arnold and
a pre-recorded introduction Spicer noted
his time in the White House tumultuous
and that he finally felt it was time to
have some fun the judges were not
impressed with Spicer's dance skills
awarded him 12 points out of 30 the
second lowest score of the night some
fans of the show complained loudly as
did high-profile ABC personnel I deeply
up her this decision by the company I
work for and truly loved tweeted Grey's
Anatomy showrunner Christopher and off I
have a question is being on Dancing with
the Stars like receiving the
Presidential Medal of Freedom
is this something we have to take with a
great level of seriousness
oh my god they were awarded Sean Spicer
one of history's greatest monsters with
on Dancing with the Stars dancing to the
Spice Girls in a lime green shirt while
playing the bongos does he deserve that
kind of honor everybody lighten up
seriously lighten up like if if Robert
Gibbs had shown up on Dancing with the
Stars what I've been like oh my god I
can't believe they had Robert Gibbs on
Dancing with the Stars this is so stupid
even the show's affable host Tom
Bergeron recently released a statement
suggesting he was disappointed by a
choice as political as Spicer really
really in it it's it's also dumb it's
intensely dumb but this is every aspect
of American life now has to turn wildly
political if he can't deal with a guy he
didn't like his press secretary who was
not super great at being press secretary
dancing the salsa on TV I suggest that
you get a life because you don't have
enough of one alrighty we'll be back
here later today with two additional
hours of content otherwise we'll see you
here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo white house key
edited by Adam Tsai events audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Jessica alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew clip
[Music]